this is a special super spooky [ __ ]
scary scariet how get on this podcast I
died one day Nomura we're in the dark
where the hotel no but it's okay he'll
go stories tonight it's festive
it's almost Holley Mangold knuckle and
teddy machine machine very much Gina
okay this time number four for you on
the pocket I don't know yeah it is oh my
gosh I'm getting my start here yeah you
need your own progress drop in the mix
remember brand oh yeah this episode is
brought to you by texture texture is an
awesome way to read all of your
magazines in one place go to texture
comm slash Jen and Julian to get started
for free right now you okay
how's everything going over there okay
so we thought you gotta be fun to have
it's also brought to you by smile direct
club.com wow that debbie awesome ways
with 3d cutting-edge technology to get
your teeth corrected check out the link
in the description they will be I'll
explain it all later it's pretty awesome
alright now to the ghost stories alright
so you better be really fun we're in
Toronto by the way above her house dr.
fest
and we thought be really fun since we
told you or I told you some my ghost
stories and last pocket not the two
pockets ago our last one last one last
one
um we didn't want to have some other
people because most people were
suggesting that we had people on to tell
scary stories
so because we had to travel you know the
best we could do is the Debbie in the
makkal but they have some good stories
we haven't heard them I haven't heard
these so you guys excited you're what
yeah alright so I I don't really have
any ghost stories but I did mention
the same as Jenna that I heard some from
this foreigner I'll sit back here I'm
scared I'm scared alright so who would
like to go first
okay yeah you go so now it's Mackel
Stern Mackel is gonna call my name at my
phone and she's gonna tell ghost story
and we all have to be quiet unless we
want to say something it's fun like this
feel free to ask questions okay
y ou know just in case oh it's not
mandatory
I was asking oh um okay so this is true
story right this is now I generally
don't believe ghost stories because I
immediately assume that the person is
you know just kind of pulling my chain
but this happened to my parents and they
told me the story off not often but
whenever I ask and I think it's [ __ ]
crazy it's super nuts
so um in a suburb of in Sydney called
Chatswood it's kind of an established
suburb with like nice old houses this
house is you know built in the late
1800s Early 1900s so it's a very old
beautiful old home that had been various
different things in its lifetime it had
been a boarding house for like older
people it had been on the whole no I
think know your people no I think oh no
old people just regular old people off
the rails already okay so um the my
parents lived and my dad is a twin so my
parents lived there for two years before
they got married it as a twin yeah Helen
Jim Allen Jim
uh-huh their Twitter and their dad is a
twin ah yeah
crying I know you messed with their
thyroid boys are famous in in Australia
so Helen Jim and and my mom before they
were married moved into this house Helen
Jim bought the house they moved in the
three of them and the minute
they moved in strange things started to
happen and mom says that the minute she
moved in she knew that there was
something there
she was never frightened by it she never
felt threatened by it but she knew
everyone even dad who's not super
perceptive with that kind of stuff like
he's you know he was he knew that
everyone just kind of knew there was
something from there so because they
were you know these kind of successful
young dies you know my dad obviously was
with my mum at the time but Uncle Jim
was a little you know he was a bit of a
playboy and whatever so they used to
have parties often and and the two guys
would travel making you know films and
whatever a mum was at home so a lot of
there were a lot of you know different
things that happened so a couple of the
stories that they they've told they
would they once had a huge party and
there were you know maybe 20 30 people
in the room and there was this huge
crash in the kitchen through double
doors from the living room where they
were all having this party was these
double doors into this kitchen and a
huge crash like mum describes it as
being it sounded as though the cupboards
on the walls and everything inside them
had crashed to the floor yeah every 130
people in the room were like holy [ __ ]
what was that like everyone they all
like whoa thinking there was you know
the kitchen had exploded in red and they
ran in nothing's out of place
another thing I should mention from day
one their dog
used to come in the house and that's how
H is a really bad guy really really and
I you can get funny yeah really and so
on but yeah mum was always like that's
weird
I'm sensing something this is and then
[ __ ] started to happen
nothing was out of place in the kitchen
like ever nothing was out of place but
everyone heard it yeah another time
there was mum said there was 20 people
in the living room same living room and
the doors double doors like French doors
out to the patio a balcony that veranda
thing um
flew open like burst open everyone went
woah [ __ ] like muggy Monsieur de time
there was 20 people in the room it flew
open everyone was like what the [ __ ] and
then slammed shut
Oh many people can say 100% we saw that
with our own eyes another time um so
like I said my uncle was single right so
he'd have girls come over and stay and
whatever and anyhow guess that they ever
had that would stay all woke up they
didn't know one another they would all
wake up seeing the same thing that they
felt as though they had a hot poker
going through their heads and that half
their body was fire and half their body
was ice and then this is literally these
women didn't know one another they some
of them were dating Uncle Jim some of
them were just like friends who were
staying over after a party and it was a
big old you know house that was the
party house and so people here come up
so um and then one of the craziest ones
for me I think this is not mum said that
like like I said she was never
threatened by this presence right if
anything you know that it kind of became
like just like part of everyday you know
um she said there was this door the back
door that she would go and physically
shut the door and lock it turn the lock
the bolt
and she would come back like when Uncle
Jim and Howard out of town she was there
in the house alone she would come back
after a minute or something and the door
was physically open a jar and so she'd
be like ah man I just wanna go to bed
like come on like please let me walk
yeah and so she'd shot it lock it walk
away and be like we done like she's
totally chill by I cute go yeah like the
boom yeah baby grand through so mom and
dad even ended up married getting
married in the front yard of the house
and they lived there for 4 years 2 years
prior of their marriage and then 2 years
after and so they loved the house it's
not like you know this goes like you
know scared them outta yeah um so then
one night a they were having another
party and mum was telling the stories of
all the happenings to someone at the
party and one of their other guests
overheard and said oh yeah you know you
have someone here her name is Amelia
Gillan crest she was the housekeeper for
a family that lived here how long I
don't know but um and she and she said
amelia is leading me over to this linen
closet which is where she did like most
of her work was folding the linens and
putting them in this closet and so you
know mum was like yeah I looked like
yeah that's the linen closet and she
said that she perceived that amelia
fancied my uncle and so so every young
girl whenever had girls over she was
jealous and she was like oh my god yeah
she was like a woman you know you know
20s or 30s you know keep up so I was the
thing like goes can like they attach
those to people whether you know and
apparently dead to the other day that
apparently the story goes that she had
lost her husband like tragically and
that this this friend of theirs was
that she was like trapped in exile or
something like she wouldn't leave
because you know there was and so I
guess her husband died tragically so she
kind of attached herself to Uncle Jim
yeah crazy that's crazy
and in my aunt my aunt Virginia I know
eyes with their I know dude up with the
dark she's trying to go friend yeah you
know um and shocks girls I noticed like
us well I'm over here ghosts all right
you got one more room all right now call
your up okay so my other story is a
little more recent it involves Colin my
husband and I and he was I think I
remember this when I was living with him
I'm sorry sorry sorry when I first met
him he was living with his brother and
his brother's girlfriend in a really
cool old bungalow in Santa Monica and um
there have been some things that had
happened like doors kind of closing um
Harper who's my now sister-in-law would
say that you know she would wake up and
the door was you know closing slowly and
squeaking and you know things like that
but they could somewhat be explained um
but then there they had LED light doors
to the cabinets in the kitchen yeah and
you know that LED light just makes it
that really distinctive look green we no
no no like that the glass panels shaking
when they're not secured in the ledge
right they make that kind of rattling
yeah sounds like what yeah yeah it's
kind of like this rattling of the glass
you know because it's and and Harper
would be there alone the boys were out
whatever and hot with Errol and she
could hear the kitchen things rattling
you know which again could
explain whatever weather - maybe it's an
earthquake asylum so the first night
that I went on a I think Colin and I had
been dating for a little while but it
was the first time that we went on like
a group date with his brother and Harper
he's now wife so the four of us went out
to dinner and movie whatever we came
back sitting in the kitchen all for uh I
think cabin Harper were in the other
room so it was just callin an eye and we
were sitting at the bar in the kitchen
and they were I was on one stool Colin
was at the table and there was a stool
in between us and we were just having a
normal conversation and stool moved an
inch
slid across and moved an inch and at
first it was so like weird and small and
we were kind of here - happened down
here that we kept talking and then after
a minute I was like did you see that and
he goes [ __ ] yeah I didn't want to say
anything cuz I totally think this house
is haunted and they're like I was too
scared to kind of tell you I was like I
totally just saw that so I didn't know
of the happenings that you know so then
a couple of weeks later we were watching
a movie on the couch cam and Hawk were
gone sitting on the sofa and really cool
a bungalow right that had the ceiling
had been taken out and so it was just
the rafters with the exposed beam this
is the one that I remember so we were we
were lying on the couch watching this
movie and all the lights were off and we
both saw um it was a mass lighter how to
describe it other than like a cloud move
from the tip across the ceiling above us
and I'm literally getting jungles like
it was [ __ ] terrifying and I
immediately said I just saw something
and Collin goes I did too he goes did
you see it right there and I said no I
saw it there I literally saw it moving
across the room above us
so weird yeah and so that was I mean it
was a it was I only experienced I was
too but those guys living there like
Colin was like it would have often there
would just be things like doors shutting
things moving you know being like you
put that there and then you know just
like me and stuff like that that you
could you know but but I physically saw
the chair move and a black man and a
mass move above me want to describe the
bass like like um cloudy like a cloud no
it wasn't like it like an opaque cloud
it was it was like I like what's the wow
oh you're gonna say the Pokemon like the
dark the black Rob [ __ ] put yeah
no you know um I mean I honestly don't
know what to compare it to but it's like
it was almost like smoke I could see
through it easy to see but it was almost
kind of as it moved it kind of just like
amorphous like a kept kind of changing
shape change shape and it wasn't a round
object but it was round dish but yes it
looks like the cloud like is in an ad no
but it was moving and so and then it was
clear you could see through it but it
would almost distort things as it moved
you know I know it's you you can
definitely even in your peripheral you
could see that it was moving and it I
mean you you saw it physically move I
saw it physically go from here to here
and Colin saw it go from here today so
you have both you both saw it when they
saw it had it by like you know adding up
the two blacks that both come on both
like holy [ __ ] did you to see that yeah
so we both we both said at the same time
oh my god did you to see that and I was
like yes I saw it go from there daddy he
was like I saw it above at the same time
oh yeah I'm sorry I'm gonna dance my
resume I was [ __ ] terrified I was so
but I would lived in Hollywood at the
time so driving back from Santa Monica
Hollywood it was like just so I had to
but I mean every time I stayed over
there I was it was uneasy I just felt it
yeah and I'm Colin said that when he
moved out when he and I got a place
together from there and he when you know
everyone had moved out he was the last
one there cleaning up late at night and
I think a bank I think a broom fellas a
it wasn't even a ghostly thing it was
like him tripping or something but he
was like Tara ran our house was like
never going to I don't even care if the
house is dirty I don't get my deposit
you cannot go back in there that's so
scary
yeah [ __ ] terrifying yeah so I'm a
true believer Wow when that makes me
honestly yeah cuz as much as you're like
makkal like I do trust you well I'm not
gonna lie about something like that you
know in like real quickly guys this
spooky episode of the Jenna Jillian
podcast is brought to you by smile
direct club calm smile direct club uses
proprietary cutting-edge technology
basically 3d printing to help avoid the
inconvenience and cost of visiting your
dentist or orthodontist which can cut
costs up to 70% smile direct Club liners
cost a single payment of $1500 with lab
costs waived and other invisible aligner
brands can cost up to five thousand
dollars on average or you can take
advantage of an easy payment plan with
only 250 dollars down and ninety nine
dollars a month for 15 months no credit
check required treatment time averages
from five months but ranges from three
to ten months it can also be an easy
solution who have had braces fail to
wear the retainers in teeth shifted back
right now you can save 50% off the cost
of a smile direct Club evaluation by
visiting smile direct club comm / Chen &
Julian unfortunately this is unavailable
in North Carolina but everywhere else in
the u.s. you can access this check it
out it's smile direct club comm / Jenna
Julian it's also brought to you by
texture cause you know we love texture
thanks to pizza we're all binge eating
thanks to Netflix we're all binge
watching but now with texture you can
start injure eating trust me
it's about to be a thing when it comes
to magazines guys you know what you like
I know what I like I like Men's Fitness
I actually read bicycling sometimes
backpacker automobile depending on my
mood there's tons and tons and tons of
magazines on the texture app and you can
tap into them with your smartphone
anywhere anytime with the texture app
you even get certain articles and
magazines curated for you depending on
what your
reading my textures team which is
awesome it's a great way to discover new
content and right now you can get a free
trial with texture by going to texture
comm slash Jenna Julianne you'll gain
immediate entry into all the top
magazines including back issues and
bonus video content so start binge
reading for free right now when you go
to texture comm slash Jenna Julian
that's texture comm slash Jenna Julia it
is now the Devi machine turn machine by
the way it's pretty much just gonna be
us reacting to debian rubber sorry yeah
okay I feel like I could listen to
people tell me yeah yeah I love control
disorders last week and I'll have yeah
just make the mmm the first story I'm
going to tell is about when I was in
college and my sister lived with a woman
I think her name was Christine but she
was a she read tarot cards but she
didn't like doing it because it scared
her faired if she had done it for a long
time she I don't know if she had grown
up doing it or whatever but she was a
very serious person so she wasn't like
the kind of thing where he looked at her
and went oh you know she's kind of a
flake you know but for some reason she
decided to read I don't know if it was
just me or whatever she rep she went
these cards and she I had just moved I'd
come back from Europe and I just got an
apartment with another woman and we were
this was in western Massachusetts and
the apartment was pretty far out but we
had just signed a lease and we had moved
in there and I had gone back down to
Cape Cod to visit my sister and with
with Christina think her name was
and so she's reading my tarot cards and
she said well first of all you got to
live with a dark-haired man and I'm
thinking to myself I just rented an
apartment I'm not going to live with
another guy there's no there's two
brooms we're not going to get some guy
to live there it doesn't make any sense
so I didn't say anything out loud and
then I said then she goes and you know
there's going to be a dog that lives
there too and I'm like I'm allergic to
dogs don't dogs gonna come this is
ridiculous and then she said and the
last thing is you're going to find
something that's very valuable she said
but it's very strong getting goosebumps
just thinking about it it's very strange
because it's very cold this object
and you're not going to know that it's
valuable but when you realize that it's
valuable she said I don't understand why
is it cold she said at first I thought
it was like a gem or something maybe
like you know a nice like a diamond or
something that was like coal but she
said that's not it she said it's just
it's freezing cold and it's you have it
and you don't know how valuable it is
yeah okay fine and but she was very
convincing she was at a very like nice
style about her so I go back to college
and it turns out that we met this guy
that we went to Community College with
and he said oh my laughs I just rented
an apartment I need two roommates and
I'm just getting goosebumps just talking
about it and he said and we're like you
know what that apartment that we rented
it's too far out I want to fill in us
out of our rent out of our lease and he
did the guy let us out of our lease and
we moved in with this dark-haired guy
right Richard right and so I'm starting
to get like okay wait a minute she just
said that this was like man like like a
couple weeks right and and I have known
very well need of us doing very well
they all had our own room it didn't
really matter so the next thing I know
like the following week he goes look I'm
gonna go get my dog from home and I'm
gonna bring it up here it was a basset
hound I mean the dog was ridiculous I
mean he made soft-boiled eggs for the
dog on a doggy when it had a peanut
butter toe so you guys have did that
that's anyway yeah that's even better
Jose had to be folded in half it wasn't
folded over like it was in a beagle was
it oh the bastard so that's how that's
right and as soon as he left a single
howl all day long anyway sorry I digress
so so then I'm like okay
2:03 I hope you don't be mad at that
right and I'm like right that I'm not
even allergic that's adorable the dog is
it oh he's a person and so then I said
okay 203 okay you know who knows maybe
you know I still don't know what so that
I'm thinking mostly she didn't get that
other thing because I'm a poor college
kid with no money and I came back from
Europe with a dime and I think I had $11
in the bank I had no money whatsoever
but I was a French major and so I had
these books and so I was at school and
at university and for some reason one of
my my grandma professor was talking
about these books that she had them she
had one of them right there she goes it
was I remember distinctly it was a large
almost like an encyclopedia size it was
pretty thick it was like two or three
inches thick and it was blue and she
said if you ever get a chance to even
look at one of these you should because
they're extremely rare and very valuable
and I'm looking at I'm going I had one
of those at home I said to her she does
honey you don't have one of those at
home you know you can't possibly there
they're like a thousand dollars and
they're very rare you couldn't possibly
have it and I said well okay I think
anything's possible Halloweeny alone
right so I said I think I do so I go
home wait let home go back to the
apartment the same way her apartment
right I go back to the apartment and I
bought the room that I had - this is no
in the mountains in western
Massachusetts it was on the north wall
and there was a bookcase there and I
went over to touch just look to see if
the book and it was freezing cold oh my
god okay really quick
was it cold inside that room no because
it was like a room you know exactly room
yeah but it's against like the law it's
against this wall with the weather again
listen you know the wind blowing against
this wall so that the probably a lot of
the books in the bookcase were pulling
how cold really really cool like
freezing because the wind and everything
was the wind and everything would blow
against that wall and there were prefab
places that came from Virginia's they
really had no business being in that
climate but no you could there wasn't
like regular you know could not be in
the room yeah we lived there regularly
but so this book was just I mean it was
absolutely like like frozen yeah and all
I could think of was you know what how
does she do that
how did she know it's always you do with
dad you know it's all in the book I
didn't sell the book but I ended up
giving it to a place where you know I'm
so stupid right but
I didn't I didn't want to sell it I
ended up giving it to this place that
would preserve it for disgrace it
wouldn't you know because what was like
a we're going to sell it I have money
and now I'm what the person's gonna
wreck the book or whatever and it was a
really cool book behind me so that's
that's that story where'd you go up in
the book I don't remember where I got
this book I you know what I racked my
brain about that
I think someone gave it to me and I was
just like this French like book and so I
was thinking you know I'm still like if
somebody gave you a book back then you
kept it like now with right right right
the same there so I but I don't remember
where it came from or anything like that
and me I you know part of me thinking I
don't even remember getting it you know
any me that's kind of odd it was sort of
like just like on the Shelf yeah it's
crazy
but in the day in those days you know I
didn't have anything I would have some
clothes in my books where basically all
you had right I remember leaving
wherever I went I would have my car in
my car would have some books and you
know maybe if maybe a few dishes or
something but you don't have you didn't
have anything and I was happy I hadn't
care anyone the other sort I was going
to tell is question yes you had a tarot
card reading sense well interest it's a
perfect segue yeah yeah yeah so yeah
people who know me know that I'm a night
roller umm machine where say meal of the
year machine works it all down right so
I look for some reason I wake up at 3
for whatever time in the morning and I
just wake up and so I I know I can't go
back to sleep right away so I get on
Twitter or on periscope and just go on
periscope and see what people are doing
yeah not all the time but you know once
in a while so this was just this just
happened last week so I get on periscope
and
aiesec you know I just scroll through to
see what people are doing and there's a
guy reading tarot cards on there and
apparently somebody that I follow but I
don't remember following him and he said
it was saying wrong he has a very he's
American because that's like this
unusual accent and his voice was like I
don't know I was like silky kind of you
know like almost I don't know I don't
like seductive in a way but not I don't
mean like not sexual no something like a
suit like Alice like Svengali kind of
like oh you know what is he saying but
he was doing somebody else's reading and
he was flipping the cards and um I
didn't know you know I'm I'm just
listening I'm not even really paying
attention to what he's telling this
woman and she's saying oh yes I
understand I agree because you're on
periscope so he's talking and the other
person is common in commenting in the
chat typing things in so he gets done
with her and then he says I think I'm
gonna do one more I know I thought I was
going to stop but I thought I think I'm
gonna do one more and we said if you're
interested put your name in and then
we're like 30 or 40 people there so I'm
like okay I'll just type in Deborah you
know I'm gonna pick me there's like 40
people here thirty people here and so
he's shuffling his deck and he goes I'm
gonna pick Deborah I gotta give up this
tarot card pair yeah yeah yeah well he's
kept saying I haven't been here in so
long so I must have seen him sometime in
the past because I was following him and
I hardly thought of anybody anyway he
said I haven't been here probably in a
year um oh man okay so it's alright
alright okay so I'm like okay and I tend
to believe but I also tend to be fairly
skeptical but I have a fairly practical
person so they so many of the scam of
fake ones yes they're so rare to find so
and like the with the cult book it's
like you know
but anyway so he says Oaks we start
shuffling the deck he goes okay well
there's somebody here I think it's your
I think it's your mother your mother's
here is your mother passed and I said
yes she's waiting he's also a medium
yeah yes yeah he's a medium that's what
he's using the cards actually as an item
all right sorry yeah I should have said
that so he uses yeah uses a card just
that's right I didn't think of that
you're right yeah because the whole
thing is weird and I the one the lady
before me was getting her reading I'm
thinking I wonder if she's like taping
it and writing it down or something you
know cuz it's like he's saying all these
things and it's easy for to just go by
right
is he getting it right for her was she
she was saying yes
right yeah and she knew him it was her
birthday and they apparently knew her so
anyway so he says your mother's here and
he said she has a genie is that right
now people who know my mother you know
know where as Patricia Moore Trisha
but that was really her middle name her
first name is Genevieve which is begins
with a G so I'm like okay would obscure
letter right G gonna be like yes right
letter someone's mother that's great and
Genevieve is you know not not a real
common name right how many girls names
even begin with G I don't know
so anyway I'm like okay she's here so he
said to me she's showing me he said oh
she's really animated I'm like yep
that's her and he said oh she's she's
showing me around where she passed
there's all these things of water and
you know there's bowls of water all
around and honestly I have no idea what
that is but there's bowls of water so I
got you know who knows this was only
last week and then he said
oh he said now she wants me to tell you
that something she didn't approve up
before she does approve up now do you
know what that could be and I said I
don't you like tagged in the chat yeah I
said I don't know and he goes well I
don't know either but she's really
making it clear that whatever she didn't
like before she likes now and it's okay
so you should just go for it full steam
and I said well I am working on maybe a
book and he said well she's saying don't
go back and edit anything just keep
writing and writing and writing and the
books gonna be very successful okay
whatever
and then he said now what's the deal
with you and mirrors and I said whoa you
mean
and he said well she's showing me all
these mirrors and she said you don't
like mirrors and I'm like well it's not
that I don't like them I just I'm not
you know I'm not the kind of person who
spends a lot of time looking in the
mirror just just how I am
and he said well she's just showing me
mirrors and mirrors and mirrors and
mirrors and I said well you know she was
a very vain person and she you know
cared a lot about her parents so maybe
it's that and he said well I'm here too
I'm not here to help you figure it out
I'm just here to report what the
person's telling me and there may have
been some other things but that's all I
could be memory from that and then so he
said so so she just keeps showing me the
mirrors and she's she's leaving now
she's going and I said well
very much and then he said he had this
big glass of water or something it
didn't look like water it looked like
iced tea or something like that he goes
I'm so thirsty he's like that that
spirit she just drained me of all my
water I'm just like such that I'm so dry
what is with that I'm like true I don't
know I know nothing I know nothing so
does that have any significance the
water thing no I think she's just very
high energy
like if you're a medium and you're
traveling so when the fast energy is
taking me say to me oh yeah yes mom high
energy given last week it was so weird
so what you said I'd you have an story I
said I couldn't believe when you said
that do you want to do the podcast or is
it like literally just happened like the
night either the night before or two
nights before that's crazy
it is so weird when you said that so Wow
yeah so I've had a couple of I was
telling wrong that I live in New York
and there's a place called lily Gale
which is a place where mediums and live
in a village and oh yeah imagine that
village this yeah that's great you
imagine that when you told me but I
didn't hear about it so Lily Dale is um
it probably had in the summer and the
warm weather there's probably I would
say I'm guessing but I'd say maybe 100
mediums that live there and some of them
come for like two weeks and of marvered
for me it's like the Harvard for
meetings and there's you know they
support each other and there's
certifications and credentialing it's
it's very different than you might
imagine
but I've had two different readings but
the last lady that I read the red being
she when I went to her she said you know
your as a two ative as I am and you
could be doing what I'm doing and I said
oh no that's way too scary I mean you
know I would not want to do that
but the lady that the firt weren't the
first time she goes you are audio Philip
I said well what nun named heaven
Atlantean yeah
and she said you don't necessarily see
ghosts you hear them and so ever since
she said that I paid a lot of attention
to that I have some level of rain in my
ears because I'm you know not a kid
anymore I listen to a lot of very loud
music for a lot of years um so so I
don't know if it's that but I can tell
you that I have the like it's not a deja
vu because that's something different
and I have those this is like it's very
very very creepy although I'm trying to
like embrace it yeah he opened it so
instead of being afraid of it you're
trying to like go with it but it's a
sound and it sounds it first sounds like
this room like really loud
mmm like someone's trying to talk but
it's getting warped
like that but I like I know that in one
year both ears
oh it's in both okay yeah and how often
does this happen it happens kind of a
lot lately but like once a week once a
day I would say a couple times a week
and then it's like someone trying to say
hello but it's getting warped yes have
you ever tried to just sit
and listen in a book well yeah and just
like sit and peace and be like I'm I'm
open and what I want to listen have you
tried to actually know cuz I'm too
scared yeah yes please very alright
maybe you don't have to be scared so
what's happening more now than it used
to way more now than again I would say
in the last year and do you think that's
because you're just more open to it
yeah like have you noticed ever since
you've been more accepting of it that
happens more I think I think it's
because I'm not so overwhelmed and
exhausted all the time and I think I'm
just more at peace with myself and so
the ability for this sound but you know
I can try this which is when it happens
and I it doesn't happen at any
particular time of the day like it's not
like it's first thing in the morning or
late at night or there's no rhyme or
reason oh I that I can see no there's no
pattern that I can see you can look up
online too if you think that you're
you're clairaudient like what's the best
way for me to start like tapping into
that you know like what's the best
energy approach to like sit down and let
whoever's trying to talk to me talk to
me well I can tell you that I know it's
scary but Liam just try it and if it
terrifies you don't don't do it right so
I can tell you that I do a fair amount
of volunteer work and also sort of
spiritually my way of being in the world
is if I meet someone then if I can bring
the light of the people that love that
person to them so I feel like it passes
through me and it's like it's not any
effort at all yeah so it might be
somebody behind the counter it might be
somebody whose business I'm helping it
could be a complete stranger it could be
somebody I love but I it's always the
same process which I almost empty myself
out it's like I don't even really
realize I'm doing it and then these
words just come out of my mouth
and they're like and they said oh how
are you why you know that's like the
perfect thing just what I need to have
like it doesn't have anything to do with
me I didn't I'm not saying it so in a
way
a you know like this guy he was saying
when he saw the mirrors of the bowls
with water it's like a symbol so it's
almost like I'm empty and it's just
coming through it's not you're a vessel
right I'm not even really and so I said
they say to people look I don't know
what I said I'm not saying I have no
memory I but I'm just saying I didn't
like you man that out yeah so you know
if you want to write it down or whatever
you're gonna have to because don't come
back and ask me that I have no idea so I
think I'm practicing it in a way but not
not this not that rule it's making me
really in the air to hear that yeah I'm
sure and it's always that sound it's
always that same sound or a variation on
that sound that's like thinking is it
ever don't have a physical reaction to
that public public like around other
people where you hear that distinct
sound you're like that couldn't have
been anyone else is rather as a rule it
doesn't happen in public but it can
happen anytime yeah it's happened as I
said morning noon and night the scariest
time is if I'm awake at night oh my god
thing is how I come to be on periscope
because if I'm just there my legs you
know can't go back to sleep it's like I
don't want that sound to come but maybe
I can embrace it in a new way that well
maybe is just someone that really wants
to talk to you
yeah yeah my knee up like one person
right and there's there's that theory
about time is not linear you know
everything this has Handy's sorry and
it's lots of those things yeah so if
that you know if you believed in one of
those theories you could say that the
same thing that dimension right like I'm
just winding up yet right you know
happens to go by and I happen to be a
year in the wall at the time when I see
happening you seem to be a big that is
very cold and like available
yeah right so whether it's a you know a
spirit or whether it's you know this
multi-dimensional time thing or whatever
right you know it doesn't really
you know as long as it's being used for
good and popping and positive and
powerful then that's that's good you
know wow that's a great story I did
something that I kind of have always
kind of realized about myself but only
set it out loud
recently and it's funny damn stories
making me think of it so it's I will
often see something happen before it
happens but it will it will manifest in
a different way and I only very recently
told Colin about it I was like this
happens to me it's always happen to me
but it happens to me regularly where and
I've got to listen to my intuition more
because it just happened the other day I
I saw my favorite wine glass sitting
sorry my favorite wine glass was in the
cupboard and I saw another wine glass
that I don't enjoy using so much because
I'm weird like that on the dish rack and
I thought I'm gonna get a glass of wine
I should use that wine glass yeah but I
was like no I'm gonna be an [ __ ] and
get my special wine glass so I grabbed
my special wine glass and as I grabbed
it I shot the cupboard and it got caught
and smashed and I was like that was my
body that was everything in me telling
me to not grab the glass at the time and
that [ __ ] happens all the time like I
sometimes I get really worried because
it's it's literally always right if I
listen to it I'm not going to learn to
listen to it but I now sometimes get
very terrifying flashes of car crashes
and stuff if I'm like about to jump on
the freeway and I get I've gotten off
the freeway many time just because I'm
like I do not want that one to come true
yeah and so I will avoid things or if
I'm like walking down the street I will
cross the street if I have like a flash
of something that's like don't you know
don't get that wine glass use this wine
glass if I get it if I get that sense if
I'm walking down the street or driving
or about to reach for something I'm like
I'm gonna wait and I'm gonna come back
and do that later you know and it
happens often we're talking about the
last episode about deja vu and how we
think one theory is like in your past
life something very similar to what
you're experiencing with deja vu have
happened and so you're reliving it right
so what makes me like tripped out about
that is like all these instances where
you're having these these kind of
moments where you have a feeling of
knowing what's going to happen or what
might happen or what could happen if you
do something makes you feel like that's
like it applies you know like maybe in
some past life all of these instances
happened and you didn't listen to any of
them and they all happened can I tell
you my story yeah so the only time I
guess the time that got me most like
opened everything's always been
relatively open you know that and like
weird stuff has always happened but the
weirdest and the thing that finally
pushed me over the edge of life this is
a good thing and this is cool and all of
my college roommates were like making
fun of me
it was about a week or two weeks or
something that was happening so it
started off that I went to class and it
was a history class which I'm terrible I
was like art history or something and he
started our teachers started writing on
the board like any other day and I
flipped to a new blank page of my
notebook so I'm at my current page of
notes
yesterday's notes flip the page and
there's like two and a half pages of
notes already taken and I was like okay
tight uh maybe I don't remember this day
and as he starts drawing things on the
board they are in my notebook yes in my
handwriting in my pen and every single
thing that he says and is drawing for
yes so I started all I was trying not to
freak out and the kid next to me was his
name was Jake he was on the baseball
team I just look over him like yo dude
we already take these notes and he was
like no ad this is like this is new
stuff today so I'm like sick type 6a so
I'm looking at my notes every word
forward like I took the notes already so
I'm trying to freak out close my
notebook you know go home for the day or
whatever and I'm telling like Jackie and
I'm like the weirdest [ __ ] thing
happened to me like I don't
explain it but like I'm just going to
try and chalk it up as whatever because
I don't know what else to do with it and
then we sat down we were watching like
cheaters or like some show some yet but
I don't think it was bad but it was like
you know some like the challenge or like
some into the show something and it was
new that night and we had never seen it
before and yet I knew everything that
was going to happen I did the same thing
and I was like is this hope is this last
week's episode and she was like no this
is new and I'm like you gotta [ __ ]
kidding me
so it's the little thing though it was
the notes that was the biggest but
physical proof but for the rest of that
like week or two my friends were like
dying laughing me house it has a power
universe going Jenna like it's actually
[ __ ] sick because I got straight A's
in every class it was like I had already
known all the material I've already
taken all the tests and I was getting so
many [ __ ] A's and I was like please
stay forever power of the universe and
then it finally went away yeah but I was
having these like experiences of like I
have literally already done this right
but those notes in my notebook was like
the most next level how does that
explain I don't know why not write like
slept walked and then gone no the only
way that Hey what it's no explanation no
he only hadn't been to the cloth
reactions not even know the only way
that I've been able that's why I feel
like I'm so open because my biggest
experience the although he's aren't
really ghost stories there's like yeah
biggest experience has been so
incredibly positive like yeah it was
scary yeah yeah I can't explain it but I
was like this is [ __ ] dope it's like
a Cuban 2.0 but because they're so
positive then I feel after that you're
like open your okay you know like it's
jarring but um yeah I can't I have no
idea yeah and you don't know you know
what what it's trying to do yeah yeah or
or what why is happening
no the only way that I was sorry to
answer question explaining it's like
maybe I just shifted into another
parallel dimension all right maybe I was
in a parallel dimension and took rice
and somehow I have my notebook from you
give it a parallel dimensions that like
you never know where they exist early if
it could you could you can be movable
Jana is sitting for the same on history
clone oh maybe the books just got
switched yeah I mean like something that
really could be minuscule right bring
your backpack but the portrait it's like
super cool that BA all of a sudden now
you're experiencing something regarding
and it was only you know two weeks of
time right I just realized nothing that
happens to me really a lot I know but
I'm in denial about it and I'm just only
saying that now because you guys are
reminding me I'll be singing a song in
the card and I turn the radio it's on
yeah but it's like really be really but
not like an ollie radio so twice oh no
what happens to me a lot and every time
it happens I'm like oh there do it again
oh no no but it doesn't happen that much
but now what I'm thinking about there
yeah and it's like how can that how
could that possibly be how I can't how
can I know that that songs on these
things of like like that that's not like
a popular song I don't listen to pop oh
yeah right I'm like listen to oldies and
all kinds of weird stuff yeah okay go
ahead
no I was just gonna say like things like
that and and that sort of thing you were
talking about like when you kind of have
an idea of what's going to happen if you
if you listen to it it'll happen those
are the closest experiences I have had
to anything like this and those are so
minimal and I think they're minimal
because when they happen I try to just
like not think about it like that was a
weird coincidence but then it happens
again and again right I think I kind of
know deep down that's not a coincidence
right but at the same time I think it's
gonna take too much out of me to try to
figure out what it is and so I intuition
yeah but like I like to think that if
I'm scared of something if I think of
every possible scenario that means it's
not gonna happen
yeah right for sure I'm as well because
I just thought of it now with jinxed
everything right
not going to happen Mysore um the
biggest example of what happens to me is
I saw our car accident before which is
why I said when we said whatever I have
that feeling I get off the freeway as we
were driving from my sister's house in
Hollywood back to work on and I lived at
the time in Santa Monica so we were
coming down the hill of the 405 into
into Santa Monica you know and that like
Hill in the rain never rains in LA when
it does the roads get really slick and
dangerous because the oil rose up months
with no rain and we were driving on the
101 hadn't even got on the 405 yet so
for anyone who doesn't live in LA would
understand that's like you know 10
minutes 15 minutes I guess and I was we
were driving Collin was driving and we
had the two dogs in the car and I
thought to myself in there was broken
glass the dog was in the back I mean it
was all very you know and I kind of
started panicking but I was like no just
block it out you know and then ten
minutes later we had an accident that
didn't resemble the what I saw it was
nowhere near as bad but it was it was an
accident in the fast lane on the 405
where you know we locked out like there
was a car spinning mmm right down and so
everyone slammed on their brakes to
avoid that car and our brakes locked up
and we just smashed into you know two
cars and and you know I mean I was I was
plenty that was you saw the spinning so
that's anyway see but that wasn't our
car but it doesn't matter like that was
when I was like I mean I've always seen
stuff moments before but this was one
that gave me enough time that I should
have thought we need to get off the
freeway and
random I swear I'm not even driving and
I'm like we need to get off the freeway
we need to we need to change streets we
need to change this situation right now
because you know and people think I'm
[ __ ] crazy icons like Rome nothing's
gonna happen and well I trusted and as
well but literally as we were hitting I
was like I saw this I knew this was
gonna happen I knew that's all I was
yelling the news was gonna happen I knew
this was call it was like what are you
talking about
and I literally saw it minutes before it
happened
yeah and that's when I was like I really
have to listen to yes right and if it is
of someone who's watching over you right
say whatever that is and my kind of
beliefs see those saying like that that
someone's coming so you know listen to
that like you're what you were just
saying Julian when you have that don't
like judge right Jenna's right if we can
listen to it like the other day I just
got off the high was poring writing it
off the highway by mistake on a world I
didn't mean to get off there and it was
like okay I'm supposed to go on this
ride yeah that's exactly right here yeah
and go slowly got me off the freeway at
night you were lost in my log and
something like intervened with your
decision right and I got off on a plate
I never get off you there right and it's
a but I got off I'm like okay this is
good you're right nice enough we're
actually just trying to be aware of it
right it's just racing yeah listen to it
because what whatever it is it's guiding
you and you're ready to be not so don't
be afraid yeah
[ __ ] that's what any anytime anything's
happening to me and I guess I'm just
supposed to do this right now yeah yeah
yeah it is as you are my god resident
experiences you know I I always say this
about Jenna I don't know if you've heard
me say this about Jenna but one thing
one of the things I love so much matter
but this also applies right now is no
matter what situation we're in there
will always be a point where she says
well at least write and then say
something about the silver lining of
what's going on right and it's like
literally there's no moment where she
doesn't do that like there's always a
situation where something you've seen it
wrong and every time it's a well at
least something big right and like it's
definitely even that's what it's it's
the best way to be yes my intern every
night it's not even conscious it's a lot
we run in the kitchen
yes I'm surprised around me completely
lost so lost model we lost no no I'm
like oh my God we're all gonna die
me and my brother back there like oh
yeah mom knows a landing a party in the
car um thank you both for like doing yes
this is something really really
unexpectedly awesome yeah um like I was
expecting to kind of be like creeped out
but I didn't expect to like kind of
learn things and like you know kind of
reflect I like that
thank you guys thank smackle thank you I
can't wait to hear what people tell us
yeah yeah totally but my dream is gonna
be a ton of people they're like totally
get right I'm totally right and
delicious
there was a commenter in the last one
that was clairaudient and says it was
really annoying for her and she would
politely have to tell them to [ __ ] off
sometime sure that's so crazy they
didn't care that shot until last thing
Stan commentary yeah family freaking
rocks totally well thank you guys for
watching and listening and yeah putting
up with us recording in a hotel and
thank you sponsor thank you sponsors
check the sponsors out below they're
awesome and we'll be back in front of
the green screen next week yeah alright
stuff this was a fun little saying yeah
I guess when I will travel with a little
better audio maybe yeah I wanted to be
fair we came prepared the camera our
equipment poops out the dough meant to
happen it was the ghost trying
happen yeah it's the gremlins right okay
like all the they're the mischievous and
goes the girl yeah they try to intervene
or intervene you guys makes me bye
[Music]